le challenge voile scolaire de michel
s'est déplacé du côté du sud et plus
précisément à saint pierre cette année
ce sont plus de 400 marmaille élèves de
cm1 et cm2 se sont retrouvés pour cette
compétition
un challenge qui a été l'occasion de
mesurer l'habileté de tous ces apprentis
marins tout au long de l'année en plus
pendant leurs cours de sport ça donnait
la poêle ces derniers se sont en effet
familiariser avec le monde de la voile
encadrés par leurs professeurs et du
moniteur de la ligue
cette année j'ai voulu que ça se passe
aussi à saint pierre parce que st-pierre
s'ouvre aux différentes activités
aquatiques
elle s'organise et l état à nos côtés
pour faire en sorte que la voile le
kayak des activités nautiques se
développe et que et que les enfants
prennent du plaisir comment je vois les
enfants crier s'égosiller soutenir leurs
camarades être sur l'eau et prendre du
plaisir à s'apprendre du bonheur dans ce
qu'ils font
moi je suis heureux de saint pierre qui
a accueilli ce challenge je veux
désormais se tourner vers l'océan pour
cela des mesures ont été prises par la
municipalité les départements premier de
l'urss cède les clubs à faire découvrir
ce sport aux plus jeunes
le département avec notre présidente
nassimah dindar soutient fortement
l'urss au niveau de toutes les villes du
département
c'est très important parce que nos
jeunes
eh bien ils vont acquérir toutes ses
bases sur la voile par exemple je parle
de la voile aujourd'hui parce que c'est
l'activité qui est concerné et les
villes principalement ici on est à saint
pierre la ville de saint-pierre à donner
les moyens d'accompagner notre jeunesse
sur l'acquisition de toutes les
techniques de natation déjà avoir son
brevet de natation et être à l'aise dans
l'eau pour après s'ouvrir à la mer et
aux activités nautiques se tourner vers
les sports aquatiques
quoi de plus logique pour tous ces
enfants qui vivent à proximité de la mer
les enfants qui ont d'ailleurs présenté
des travaux sur la protection des fonds
marins
l'occasion également de participer à des
ateliers autour du monde de la voile une
découverte ludique qui permet de
renforcer l'esprit de solidarité d'entre
aide au sens de la classe une forte
cohésion dans la classe et s'entraident
alors aussi bien en sport que dans les
autres matières aussonne la classe je
travaille beaucoup sur les contrats
l'entr'aide
la bienveillance et donc voilà c'est le
sport idéal pour favoriser tous à la
voile à lionel c'est aussi le sport de
haut niveau et surtout des champions qui
s'illustre sur le plan national et
international
ainsi morgan lagravière qui a fait ses
classes à la réunion participera
prochainement au vendée globe et sera en
effet sur la ligne de départ le 6
novembre aux sables d'olonne avec de
grandes chances de figurer parmi les
favoris voire de remporter cette
mythique course votre qualifier pour une
compétition noé delpech qui défendra la
france aux prochains jeux olympiques de
rio brésil